I'll be honest I'm skeptical not only of
the existence of alien technology I'm
fairly suspicious of the existence of
alien life which is a prerequisite for
alien intelligence and Technology right
so and I've made Arguments for that I
was on Joe Rogan and Lex fredman um but
I'm not the final word either you know
so caveat mtor why don't you believe
that there is alien life or any you say
you said you have said before that you
don't believe that there is alien life
or in alien life because careful about
it I don't I don't say I don't believe
like I say I don't believe in gravity
either evidence there's no evidence
that's right right but people like Jack
sarfati would say that there is evidence
and they've seen it and it's not
something you can measure and test in a
laboratory with beers it's something
that you have to see it's intelligence
it's police it's investigative work it's
police work like it's it's something
that scientists aren't going to have
access to and they won't be able to
measure and detect but it's something
exists because they've seen it and they
know they know that you know if you have
a security clearance or whatever it
might be it's it's verifiable and it's
there so I ask you are you are you a
Christian um I'm not really like
religious do you don't believe in God or
I mean I I believe in God I haven't
really explored it too much I I I
believe in something yeah I don't follow
a I don't follow a strict Faith yeah
okay that's fine you're not a practice
you know I practice right right right um
fine but um but you know people that
believe the existence of Jesus Christ
not only based on the testimonies of the
New Testament but also because they've
had personal revelation or they've been
saved salvation from by works of Jesus
that they ascribe to Jesus right um
would you would you attribute those
scientifically in any way would you say
that their their personal revelation of
Christ you know in their deepest darkest
moments they're at the bottom of a
bottle or they're at the top of the
world when they have a baby or whatever
is that a scientific claim or is that a
faith claim it's not scientific right so
in that sense that's it's okay because
faith is one thing and and science is
another thing these things that they're
talking about that they've seen with
their eyes or they've experienced and
there's some You Know cover those are
also now they're they're not only Faith
but they're also saying they're
scientific if you're making a claim that
there's there's objects and those
objects have traveled across
Interstellar distances and or unless or
as Tom dong told me on my podcast a long
time ago that those things have come
from forwards in time or backwards I I
don't fully understand right and he
can't prove it and has no chain of
evidence that traces the the alien
spacecraft that that he claims he has
evidence of um he's lost the kind of
provenance as they would call it an
antiquing um so at what level do you say
well okay that's now you're just talking
about faith which is fine you could talk
about faith all you want but you're
faith is almost like taste like I hate
fish there's no much you could take me
to the seafood restaurant down the
street and tell me how great this thing
tastes and and I'm going to say I don't
give a crap I'm not going to eat that
damn thing and you could say even as
people do it doesn't taste like fish
I'll say you know what else doesn't
taste like fish a freaking hamburger
doesn't taste like fish so I'll just
skip the middleman and I'll have my own
hamburger right so there's no amount of
that that will convince a person to
believe based on your faith in something
else which may be very visceral to you
it may have saved your life or it may
have you know made you a better man but
that doesn't have any effect on other
people and science is about the the
determination of rules and patterns
throughout the universe that hold
throughout the Universe the cernic
principle states the universe doesn't
care who you are where you are what you
are What You're Made Of what day it is
if I drop this this your gift I'm going
to wish you a happy Hanukkah so I
brought you a gift so I I got you I got
you two gifts oh three gifts um so this
is this is your gift for early Christmas
present cuz I want you to keep your anus
clean your anus so I got wow this is
amazing you got to share with Steve oh
my god oh Steve we can keep our we can
bleach our butth holes your an I you
know that NASA's considering changing
the name because it's so embarrassing to
say Ur anus right they've commissioned a
panel that's beautiful come up with the
following term urectum so uh and I'll
tell you what this is later on but if
you um if you look at something that is
uh portending you know sort of
masquerading as something that could be
scientific forces Fields life in the
universe all these things are contingent
upon the existence of life which is a
physics question a biology question
Evolution question and so they're saying
here's this thing that interacts with
some people but not others well that
violates cernic principle sorry that's
I'm going to have a problem with you if
you say that like there are only certain
people that could experience it so what
good is it you know so in other words
the only the people that want to believe
it will see it and only the people that
that already do believe it will
experience it that's not science it may
be some cult or some new thing and you
see a lot of the same types of behavior
that people get very obsessed almost
cult-like in their fervor for this Jack
is screaming out every now why want you
listen to me why won't you and I think
he's suffering a crisis of meaning and
that you know he wants to be accepted by
as many people as possible well how's
that going to happen if you keep you
know solipsistically referring back to
yourself that you can only be the one
that could be trusted with this
information and you're the only one that
could see it and nobody no matter how
much will ever get to experience your
perception your taste your experience so
I feel like it's at the highest level it
becomes pointless almost to debate these
people so what in your view what do you
think explains all these things like
Roswell and these things that these
Pilots are seeing on their Radars and
the above these nuclear bases and all
this stuff like what do you deduce from
that I don't want to avoid the question
but but I would say like what why don't
you believe in Muhammad like why aren't
you a practicing Muslim Danny it's not
fair right I mean like you might maybe
you haven't seen evidence to like it's
not up to you to explain why you're not
a practicing Muslim right it's up to me
if I was prosing as a Muslim to try to
convince you that actually Muhammad the
prophet was this and that and you should
accept him or Jesus or or Mo you know
whatever right in other words you my
lack of believing it is not a statement
about me unless you say like well what
would what in other words how can I
explain a billion Muslims um worshiping
Muhammad Allah and being PR like okay
this is something that has convinced
them so now you're asking me analogous
thing like what explains all these
things well I don't believe that they're
actually that they're representative of
a reproducible scientific chain of
events that can be tested using the
scientific method if in fact it's true
which I don't know but but if it's true
that they only reveal themselves to
certain people in certain places or on
nuclear plants you know then I have to
be very suspicious as a scientist right
I mean I'm a father so I have kids and I
look at the kids and you know if they
say like well I have an imaginary friend
oh what's his name well you can't know
you can't experience him so you know but
he's telling me to like steal money from
your W you know like okay well I I would
like to know more about that because
you're telling me that something is
happening with something I cannot have
access to because either I don't have
clearance or or the government's
conspiring to keep me from knowing that
information etc etc so what is the
information that's out there it's it's
it's too hard for me to kind of assess
the cred credibility of what's been
claimed by various people as I said
they're much more courageous they're
much braver bigger balls than I'll ever
have right that's grush whoever fravor
but that doesn't give them any extra
ability to practice the scientific
method than I have and when you I don't
know I mean it would almost be better
for me because you've you've invest
these more I'll say why I think it's
unlikely I'll never say that these they
don't exist I won't even say that what
they're claiming isn't correct I'll just
say you have to ascribe a probability
and to me the probability is very low I
can't say it's zero that they ever saw
that stuff this stuff ever happened that
that there are actually I don't want to
say that they saw it or they that there
are alien spacecraft from another solar
system somewhere else in either our
galaxy or another galaxy that has been
collected by human beings on Earth right
I'm not saying that that's what it is
I'm saying
like Ryan or the people that Ryan knows
or fraver the things that they saw what
would you imagine them being based on
your scientific perspective and your
back like you don't think that they're
Al from another galaxy I don't think
they are either yeah okay what what do
you think what do you think the
explanation for them is do you think
that it's just a construct well so what
you know the name of my podcast is
called into the impossible and and the
there often times people think it comes
from the Sherlock Holmes quote which is
that you know once you've excluded
anything no matter how crazy the the
facts that remain no matter how
impossible they are uh that is the
actual truth and and for me the into the
impossible comes from a different quote
from Arthur C Clark that the only way to
determine the limits of the possible is
go beyond them into the impossible I
have to ask what types of phenomena are
possible within the laws of physics that
I am very very conversent with and what
things would go so so to speak outside
the laws of physics you'd have to
ascribe things to that so in other words
how how many improbable things does one
have to believe to actually accept that
these things are from another galaxy
that's a separate question right so what
are they seeing so I will ask the f a
different question I'll say what are
plausible other explanations for what
they've seen um so here's here's the
statistic when uh the planet Venus is
visible on Earth about nine months out
of the year three months out of the year
it's behind the sun it's too close to
the sun it's emerging from behind the
sun you can't see it but N9 months out
of the year um in not only in uh America
but throughout the world the number of
UFO sightings is statistically an
incredibly amount more meaningful to be
detected or to be claimed during the
nine months of the year when Venus is
visible it's extremely bright if You'
ever seen it it doesn't seem to move it
seems to hover uh like the way the moon
doesn't move when you're driving the
giant Parallax of it same thing happens
with Venus it does change a little bit
it doesn't twinkle it doesn't Flash and
so millions of people literally millions
of people report it when it's um when
Venus is out the number of UFO reports
goes up dramatically in a statistically
significant manner conversely when it's
not up they go down okay so that's an
explanation for some things that people
are seeing right so if you said every
single one of those people unless
they're all right um then we can't
believe in that being a UFO okay so you
be right you be right that's Venus so
it's not a UFO we have a very good
identification and it's not even flying
it's orbiting um so other things that
that make me curious about suspicious
about these claims a lot of them are by
milit
uh pilot so what do militaries do do
they only have the best interest of
their people at heart do they do the
military ever use their own and
tragically and horribly use their own
conscripts or volunteers uh do they only
use them for beneficial purposes or for
the actual missions that they signed up
to do do they ever do scops on them of
course they do right do they ever abuse
the power the government ever abused the
power and abuse the people that are very
bravest Among Us of course they do right
um do they ever subject them to things
they would never subject ordinary
citizen to under the Constitution yes
they're exempt from certain things they
force them to get vaccines they do all
sorts of things right um and so could it
be that there are uh that they are maybe
testing these Pilots abolutely right um
furthermore what are some other types of
Technology do you think all technology
that the US inventory has or adversary
uh governments have right now is known
and is published in Popular Science hell
no of course not right so uh so
therefore there could be advanced
technology that uh that could have been
basically kept completely clandestine
until it was interacted with by someone
who thought they were a whistleblower
right so um and then is it possible to
maintain the conspiracy it would have to
be I mean David and others are alleging
there's a conspiracy to cover up these
things um and you know can the
conspiracy be maintained over eight
decades um not only between the
thousands of individuals you have to
imagine Ro let's say Roswell even though
I don't I know it's not that so don't
don't flame me on the uh on the on the
channel comments below when you like
subscribe and comment I'll drop that for
you uh and don't uh don't FL I don't
believe this but let's just say
basically something like Roswell happen
where there was a craft spacecraft in
1947 which by the way occurred very
close to the Trinity site very close to
military secret compounds and as are
many of these things cited you very few
of them are cited over Manhattan you
know in the middle of the of the uh the
thing giving Day Parade right um many of
them occur in warning areas which are
military traffic areas that even I as a
small pilot am allowed to go into so
where the Tic Tac was seen was it was an
area that's not restricted or prevented
from uh access to it's something I go
into at my risk I can get shot down they
actually use my plane as Target PR they
don't actually shoot thank God I would't
be here but there's a little Sessa and
they'll practice locking on thank God
they do I want them to train I want them
to be the best freaking fighting force
in the world I love this country I want
them to be and I want them to be
protected I want them to be safe I don't
want them to be experimented on I don't
have control over that right so there
are all sorts of things that they could
do especially during military military
are the least reliable in a certain
sense because they're probably the ones
that are most confronted with both the
adversaries highest technology and our
own their own friendly militaries you
know scops and and experiments on them
and loyalty tests and all sorts of um
false flag events or colored Wars and
all sorts of things that they can do to
sort of spoof and to train and to test
the the the the fighting forces's
Readiness and their loyalty and it's
just that's just a fact of life so and
you have to is that more plausible Danny
that and I'm not saying I'm right and
again I'm never saying this that that I
have a final word either do your own you
know due diligence you know this is not
investment advice but if you look at the
data then you compare to the alternative
hypothesis called a likelihood ratio
test this is what scientists do you say
like How likely is it that this vaccine
is going to improve your life and
prevent some disease versus it's going
to kill kill you and you know for most
vaccines it's very important to know
that likelihood ratio but you're always
comparing the null hypothesis okay the
null hypothesis is this is not going to
do any harm or any benefit or in this
case there is there are no aliens is my
null hypothesis okay then take this
ratio and we could do a mathematical
function that will predict what are the
different levels in other words should
it be uh 99% confident should it be uh
50% confident which is almost useless or
should it be
99.999% confidence in hypothesis is
called hypothesis testing and then you
have to question what if there are
aliens and you assume that they're not
so you get a false
negative okay so if Brian keing is right
then it's like I'm responsible for a
huge false negative or if you say
there's a false positive you are
claiming their aliens when there aren't
aliens those are both errors right in
both cases you're wrong you'd like it to
be there are aliens if there are aliens
you detect that there are aliens or if
there are no aliens you rule out the
existence of aliens those are the kind
of correct answers and then there's two
different ways you can be wrong false
positive false negative which is worse
like you go to the doctor the doctor
says to you Danny you got cancer which
would you rather have there be he's
false positive or false negative right
so it's it's right if but normally what
happens is you get you might get a false
negative right I mean that's much more
common because it's hard to see small
amounts of cancer for example it's also
hard to see small amounts of UFOs right
these things have been able to travel
across Interstellar distances right and
the old joke Elon Musk keeps making why
is the C you know photo quality so bad
why is the you know video you know why
is it so crappy the cell phones have
gotten so much better I think I have
some explanations for that by the way or
here's my other favorite one and again
I'm steelmanning my opponents not my
enemies just my intellectual opponents I
don't I don't believe I don't not want
to believe it by the way let me put a
pin in in the in the explanation for for
why these things keep happening where
they do but um I I and and good
physicists like Eric or others um even
people that aren't physicists that are
skeptical they um ailo is a good example
he's a skeptic he doesn't believe and
he's got vested interest in you know
millions and perhaps billions of dollars
and in in the you know Galileo project
and all the other things he's doing he'd
be great for you to talk to I talked to
him he's on here okay great so my
question is um who would be more
Overjoyed at the existence of some I
mean whatever if if again assume they're
aliens for the time being have they led
to the you know Independence Day like
destruction of the earth no right we're
still here yes you know maybe they're
planning something but like so far
they've been benevolent or benign
haven't bothered us right who would be
more Overjoyed with a race a species a
civilization of technologically advanced
aliens who would be more thrilled than
physicist we would be I mean you see how
we get with like chat GPT which is like
nothing compared to the kind of
intelligence it would take to make an
alien spacecraft that can Traverse the
Galaxy and and bend Space in Time right
in other words physicist have a vested
interest in aliens existing in other
words I will say I want to believe I
want there to be aliens to tell us about
the physics of the 29th Century I don't
want to wait that long I want to know
I'm going to live for another 50 years
maybe I want to learn as much as
possible while I'm still alive aliens
can help be the ultimate cliff notes to
help me understand it and so I have a
vested interest in their being aliens
okay but I I as I say I'm skeptical
about it okay now I mentioned there's
this there's you know kind of joke again
in Elon ISM Gotta Love Elon but he's
like oh these these aliens are so
Advanced they navigated from the closest
star system proximus andri uh B at
traveling at you know quarter of the
speed of light would take 25 years and
do Untold damage you know to whatever
biologics are in there and it would
require you know basically the warping
of SpaceTime to accelerate to these
speeds anything macroscopic like the
size of a spacecraft like a Tic Tac
almost an infinite supply of energy
propulsion Safari warp drives whatever
you want okay yeah but they crash in the
island of Catalina off the coast of Los
Angeles they they like crash somewhere
in Roswell in other words they're so
skilled that they Traverse the entire
galaxy but they can't they not really
because they crash all the time I don't
think that's what a lot of people
believe a lot of people believe that
they're from here that they're living
under the oceans and they're coming from
here they're coming under the oceans and
they're they're that's I mean that's
what SFA beli that's what a lot of
people I talk to on here believe they
they're they're not coming from other
galaxies they're actually here so like
Atlantis well yeah maybe maybe maybe
Atlantis I don't know but they think
that these things are coming from the
oceans and these things maybe live under
the oceans or they're walking am Among
Us or maybe there are people that are
out there like me and you or Elon Musk
more likely that are genetically also
like this alien race right they're
they're they look and talk like me and
you but they aren't you know they're
they don't look like the aliens we see
in the movies but they're technically
aliens and or or this technology that's
coming around that's that's flying
around that they're seeing is not
necessarily it's not coming from another
star system it's coming from here
somewhere and it's remaining hidden um
well so I I'm talking more about the uh
the types of alien like a Roswell
Roswell to my knowledge was not from the
ocean it was from another start you
recul reticulum whatever Omega so um uh
but but I just want to make a statement
about that when if you do hear that
again I'm supporting the um the the fact
pattern that's should be a men to many
members of your audience and not to
ingratiate myself but because it's
legitimate as a scientist you should
actually specify all the ways you could
be wrong right I'm telling you all the
ways Brian Keon could be wrong so in
this case though those that say that
it's impossible to believe that these
Advanced civilizations crashed you know
after navigating their whole way across
the entire galaxy right no actually it's
a a very common effect something like
six times so I don't want to say this
jinx myself I'm getting on a plane at
what an hour or so an hour and a half um
so something like six times you're six
times more likely to be involved in a
plane that crashes upon Landing than you
are at any other phase in Flight even
though the fraction of that plane being
in landing is only a few minutes or a
few seconds landing and takeoff right
both um yeah takeoff is also dangerous
but but landing in particular seems and
it's the whole Landing process not just
like couching down the runway and these
aren't fatal crashes I mean 90% of
crashes people walk away from most
commercial airlines and please God it
should hold true at least through
tonight when I get home a lot of these
things are I think um you know basically
pandering to like oh they're not there
here's you can just dismiss it because
the video quality is crappy they
wouldn't crash land if they're such
expert pilots and um and they wouldn't
allow themselves to be seen those are
completely illegitimate arguments
against it supporting a position I
believe in which or faith in or evidence
for which is that they don't exist so I
think it's important as a scientist to
do that and I think the the more you
talk to experimentalists the better
people are actually building stuff you
know grappling with lot if you brought
Edward Whitten in here you know he I
don't know if he could you know turn on
the the Wi-Fi and get the Wi-Fi up to
boot again you know theoretical physic
are very different than experimental
physicist they have a different skill
set it's much more like a mathematician
I don't think anyone say let's get the
mathematicians in here although you know
people like Steven wlfr have done things
with like alien like deciphering alien
language in the movie arrival he was a
consultant on that so and Thorn actually
did a lot of work in the movie
Interstellar so yeah these are these are
things that are of interest but I almost
I'm betting against my own self-interest